[Music]
all right last week for Trump campaign
aide George papadopolis was sentenced to
14 days in jail for lying to the FBI he
joins us in studio along with his wife
has been very outspoken in support of
Simona is with us you guys just got
married yeah we did Sean do you married
him in the middle of all this that's
true letting you were fighting for him
on TV which I liked a lot
congratulations a real killer you know
she's from Napoles she's not Russian
over these old interviews what do you
want the American people to know
especially about this professor and what
do you want what do you want the
American people to think about your
experience with robert muller how you
got tied up in this i was all over the
campaign I never met you that I know of
I don't like who George Bluth well you
know you were in one meeting with the
president or then the candidate giving
me to Russia
never met a Russian official in my life
knowingly no no tell us what you tell
the American people what you want to
tell them about your story in your
experience yeah so you know initially
when Kennedy Trump was very vocal about
wanting to work with Russia at some
level I basically thought it'd be a good
idea for him to meet Putin just for a
photo-op
that was based the basic understanding I
meet this professor randomly in Italy
who he presents himself as some sort of
high-level connected figure to both
European governments and to the Russian
government all of a sudden he introduces
me to a girl who he calls Putin's niece
she's not put in snooze I don't know who
this person was
he then can't introduce me to even the
Russian ambassador which I wanted to
meet at the time in London he then
introduced you thought you were doing
what the campaign said they want which
is better relations with Russia
absolutely absolutely so so then yeah
exactly so all of a sudden one day out
of the blue he drops his bomb on me
about emails I have no idea what he was
you know where he got this this
information from he said he was coming
back from Russia I never saw emails he
never told me where the emails were he
just dropped his bomb on me and then he
just went his own way so I don't know
what his purpose was it was incredibly
shady and to this day you know before
your sentence he came out and said no
you had never talked about these things
and you know what his lawyer just a
couple days ago went on
CNN and said he might have been working
on behalf of somebody else I did you
apologize for lying did you consciously
lie you know during that meeting that
January 27th 2017 interview I did
consciously lie you know it was why why
would you lie because it doesn't seem
like there's anything wrong at what you
were what you knew did you know anything
that was illegal I mean like all I could
say about this I didn't plead guilty to
collusion I pled guilty to lying and you
know everybody makes mistakes but
certainly I was in pleading guilty to
any sort of it would you lie people
think you're lying to protect somebody
were you lying to protect anybody the
campaign why did you feel the need or
desire to lie you know looking back I
just it's it was our chaotic moments you
know and sometimes you make mistakes
it's all I could say about it
all right now you have an interesting
story Simone in terms of this professor
how did you meet him and what you found
out things I didn't know about him well
actually share those information with
the FBI and the Congress but none of
them quoted me apart from my interviews
on TV I met the professor Massoud at
least of five years ago through the head
of a socialist group at European
Parliament is a professor at Lynn campus
in Rome which is a partner of the
company's director of in London and this
company this university trains secret
services agent of Western a tight
Western intelligence is also member of
the Clinton Foundation it claims to be
member the Clinton Foundation yes the
Clinton Foundation yes yes twice it has
been proved that yes exactly so my point
has always been how the profile of this
professor and his background fits with
the narrative of the Russian agent there
is nothing that leads to believe that is
a Russian agent as nothing Lisa billet
I'm a Russian spy
you know everything it seems to me so
fabricated so fictitious and it's just
insane and as I said I was a witness in
the case and I share this information as
a direct witness of this person with
both the FBI and Congress that's five
years in jail over this do you think you
were set up
oh I guess how did this professor get
into your life I had this guy from
Australia all of a sudden did you know
anything about
the Clinton emails that were going to be
released other than what was in the
public domain
of course not I mean no the only thing I
know is probably what everybody else was
speculating at that time was that
Clinton's you know Secretary of State
server might have been compromised
that's you know what was going through
my head and you know I met all these
random people in London I have you know
London was a very strange city for me
during those months ie that's where I
met the professor I'm a downer there I
met helper there you know they lured you
like gin and tonics and you were a
little drunk talking to downer you know
what's interesting about that Sean I've
never you know admitted to remembering
anything talk about that I remember a
lot about that meeting I remember the
context about that meeting and you know
it was it was done under extremely
suspicious circumstances you were
suspicious you thought you were being
recorded
I was so suspicious that I actually
notified FBI when I was talking to them
that I thought that donor was recording
me with his phone illegally as we all
know the five eyes country member
meaning Australia the UK is spying on an
American citizen that's at least
something a lot of people don't know and
that that information gets shared
doesn't it and that's a way to spy on
people keeping your hands clean isn't it
I don't know all I know is you know one
of our five ID allies are spying on
Americans it's illegal so whatever he
was doing I felt the need to notify the
FBI about it and I did how was Muller
and his team chief both of you I to me
were intimidating mostly one day this is
something I never said after my
interview they came to see me at the
airport while I was boarding to my
flight Rome and for Italian tourists
from visiting United States is extremely
intimidating I've got a run you could
have spent five years in jail 14 days
can you handle that I can handle it I
have a very strong wife here and we're
looking forward to moving on with our
lives and you know who knows you may
just think 14 days that's way too long
no I'm actually happy that it's not
longer for you I think you got caught up
in some of the way beyond me
thank you from an innovation
Sorey sure you come and think